في فقرتنا الصحيه في مسائل عربيه كورونا
لم تنتهي حيث اكدت وزاره الصحه السعوديه
ضروره استكمال الجرعه التنشيطيه للوقايه
من فيروس كورونا نهدف تعزيز مستوى استكمال
تحصين الفن اشاره الوزاره الى توفر جرعه
محدثه من لقاح كورونا تحتوي على تحديثات
مهمه ضد المتحورات الجديده لفيروس كورونا
وتمنح لمتلقيها حمايه افضل ضد المضاعفات
الصحيه الناجمه عن الاصابه بالفيروس هذه
الجرعه تعطى لمن
امضى الجرعه السابقه وذلك من العمر 12
عاما فاكثر اما الفئات المستهدفه للجرعه
التنشيطيه فهم كبار السن وذوي الامراض
المناعيه والامراض المزمنه اضافه الى
العاملين في البيئات التي تزيد من فرصه
الاصابه بالفيروس او انتشاره والافراد
الذين مضى على تلقيهم الجرعه السابقه شهرا
فاكثر
[موسيقى]
من جده ينورنا استشاري الامراض الباطنيه
والماضيه الدكتور نزار باهابري دكتور نزار
اهلا بك معانا في مساء العربيه رمضان كريم
هالمره مساء
اهلا وسهلا بكم كل عام وانتم بخير طيب
دكتور جرعه محدثه ضد متحورات كورونا الى
اي مدى من الناحيه الطبيه هناك فعلا جدوى
طبيه لمزيد من التحصين ضد فيروس كورونا
ومتحورات كورونا في الوقت الذي يتم الحديث
فيه ان فيروس كورونا باتت اعراضه مثل
اعراض الانفلونزا الطبيعيه
الحقيقه المتحور اوميكرون
الكثير جدا من اللي بيصابوا باعراضهم خفيف
لكن ما زال عندنا اشخاص الى الان ممكن
يكون عندهم امراض متعدده او كبار في السن
حقيقه لهم شديد فيصير لازم ياكد كل اي
تطعيم للاعراض التنفسيه لاي فيروس عاده
المناعه حقته تخف مع الوقت فبالتالي دائما
الجرعه التنشيطيه يعني احنا لو اخذنا ابسط
واشهر مثال عندنا الانفلونزا بناخذه سنويا
علشان احنا دائما الاجسام المضاده تخف مع
الوقت
والمهم جدا دائما انها ما تحصل لنا
مضاعفات مو الاصابه المضاعفات والاوميكرون
له تحورات جديده وهذا جدا محدث التطعيم
فيما ما يوازي كل التحورات الجديده
الدكتور نزار حتى
نفهم هل الجرعه التنشيطيه هي جرعه وقائيه
احترازيه ام انها جرعه ضروريه اساسيه لا
محاله بعد الجرعتين السابقتين
هي جرعه تنشيطيه الى الان
المطالب انه او كثير من النصح انه ياخذوهم
كبار السن اللي عندهم امراض متعدده او
منخفضين مناعه في كثير من الاشخاص الله
يكتب لهم الاجر بياخذوا ادويه تهبط
المناعه فبالتالي لما بتجيلهم حتى لو كانت
من سلاله الاوميكرون او من متحوراتها
بتيجي الاعراض حقتهم شديده كوني ان يكون
عندك مناعه وضمان وبالله يعني احنا نبغى
دائما ناكد رجاء لا احد يعني يشكك
فعالياتها دائما احنا دائما نستذكر الايام
اللي لا سمح الله مضت قديش كانت فعاليه
التطعيم ساعدتنا بفضل من الله انه يكون
عندنا مناعه نرجع الى الحياه طبيعي طيب
دكتور
يعني غالبيتنا مدى اكثر من شهرين على
تلقيه الجرعات الاساسيه الاولى والثانيه
اليوم لغير كبار السن لغير من لديهم نقص
في المناعه او لديهم امراض مزمنه هل من
الضروري اخذ الجرعه المحدثه
من الضروري لا بس من المرغب بالذات
العاملين في القطاع الصحي لم ياخذها نظرا
لانهم يتعرضوا بشكل دائم احيانا للقران او
هم ما هم دارين فبالتالي انت مهم جدا انك
انت تحمي نفسك لازم ناكد الكورونا موجوده
الحمد لله اخف اعراضها في المتحورات
الجديده لكن وجود التطعيمه المحدث هذا جدا
يساهم احنا احنا الان كلكم في وكالات
الانباء بتشوفوا قديش هي ارتفاع في عدد
الحالات بس الحمد لله الاعراض يعني لماذا
لماذا بدنا نسمع عن اصابات بكورونا مؤخرا
وباعراض مجهده يعني من تجربه من ناس
اعرفهم حولي
صحيح الحقيقه بتجيلهم بعض الاشخاص اللي
جاتهم متحوره
اتعبتهم تعب شديد في جسدهم في ضلوعهم
علشان كذا نقول علشان هذول اشخاص فقدوا
كثير من المناعه اللي اخذوها من التطعيم
علشان كذا جاءت الجرعه التنشيطيه مهمه
احنا بنشكرك جزيل
الشكر شكرا لكم استشاري الامراض الباطنيه
والمعديه دكتور نزار سعادتنا بوجودك معنا
دكتور شكرا جزيلا رمضان كريم لمتابعه
المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات